firebase is on the decline and by that i
mean it's javascript bundle size one of
the biggest criticisms developers have
about firebase is that it requires a lot
of kilobytes of javascript to get the
job done
a large bundle size can lead to poor
performance and a bad user experience
but i have some good news
firebase is releasing a brand new
javascript sdk that can dramatically
reduce the size of your web application
in today's video you'll learn how to
upgrade your existing firebase app to
reduce the bundle size by more than 50
and i'll also give you my first
impressions about what i like and
dislike about this new sdk
because it's filled with breaking
changes but first if you're serious
about building a firebase app
consider upgrading to pro on fireship io
to get access to my full project-based
courses
as developers we always want to use the
latest and greatest technology
gentlemen we can rebuild him we have the
technology
but at the same time we hate dealing
with breaking changes the new firebase
sdk makes it possible to build apps with
a much smaller javascript footprint but
it comes at the cost of a lot of
breaking changes that you'll have to
refactor in your code the problem is
that firebase has been around for a long
time
and it uses what are known as side
effect imports you import and initialize
your firebase app which creates a global
firebase object then extend it with
additional
functionality by importing other modules
like auth firestore storage and so on
this creates a lot of bloat
because these imports add a bunch of
functionality that you're probably not
going to use in your application for
example
your app might use email password login
but importing the auth module
adds the code for every other sign in
method on the platform which is nothing
but dead code that your end user has to
download from the network
instead of accessing methods on one
giant object with dot notation the new
sdk takes a functional approach
allowing you to import the exact
functionality that you need
and that means everything else can be
excluded from the javascript bundle in
other words it's a tree shakeable
library now another cool thing in the
new sdk
is that there's a firestore light
package firestore is the biggest
module in firebase but if you want to
use the database and don't need things
like real-time listeners or offline mode
you can use the light package which is
84 smaller than the normal package
that's pretty awesome but now let's jump
into the code and see what these
breaking changes
actually look like i'm using vt as my
build tool and the first thing i'll do
is install the firebase sdk using the
beta tag that'll install version 9 of
the sdk
but the beta tag may not be required
depending on when you're watching this
video the only important thing is that
version
9 is installed now if i go into the
javascript file it's currently empty
giving us a bundle size of 0.
the first thing i'll do is import
firebase the old way the nice thing
about this sdk
is that it gives you a compat library
allowing you to upgrade your code base
with minimal modifications to your
existing code
as you can see here i'm performing a
side effect import for
auth firestore and storage this should
look familiar
minus the compat part if you've ever
used firebase before if we go ahead and
build the app you can see that our
bundle size
is now 630 kilobytes which triggers a
warning
and broadly that compressor won't even
touch it that's kind of demoralizing if
you care about performance let's go
ahead and remove this code and look at
how tree shakeable imports work in the
new sdk
instead of a side effect import we
import the functionality that we
actually need from each individual
module
like if we want to sign up a user with
google we can bring in sign in with
pop-up
and sign out from the auth module or
upload bytes from storage to upload a
file
now one thing that's kind of weird is
that you'll notice we import a function
called get auth get storage and get
firestore for each one of these modules
then after initializing the app we need
to call that function
to work with the actual module itself
this is like an initialization step
that is required because it's possible
to have multiple firebase projects used
in a single front-end application
if you are using multiple firebase
projects you can pass the firebase app
as an argument
to give that module the proper context
in the old sdk
you would have used dot notation on the
firebase app to access the feature that
you're working with now if we go ahead
and build the app at this point you can
see our bundle size has been reduced all
the way down to 206 kilobytes
that's a third of the size it was
previously or 42 kilobytes compressed
which is a much more reasonable starting
point considering we have all kinds of
functionality ready to go in this app
now let's go ahead and put one of these
functions to use like sign in with
pop-up now in order to use it
we pass the auth object as the first
argument then the provider which might
be something like facebook or github
as the second argument one thing i don't
really love here is that for every
function
we need to pass auth as the first
argument it's not really any more code
than dot notation
but it just feels kind of awkward in my
opinion i find myself wanting to create
my own custom abstraction
like a class or maybe just a helper
function to get rid of that auth object
altogether
maybe that's just me but i'm curious
what you guys think about the ergonomics
of this stk so let me know
in the comments if you have an existing
project your breaking changes can be
overcome by simply refactoring your dot
notation to this more functional
approach
that's not very difficult but it will
require a lot of tedious code changes
overall i think this new sdk is a great
direction for firebase
and will allow them to add new
functionality to the sdk without
increasing your bundle size every time
and most importantly
it puts an end to the criticism that
firebase is just too big
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there become a pro member to see
firebase in action
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one